[Music]
it was a long and rocky road to success
for audio TV I'm getting his new solo
album together his second didn't come
easy either
as the Antonia Simon's volume at the
start the album was one big enigma for
me it's because I didn't know if I
wanted to make the concept album or very
personal one if the songs would be my
stories or invented ones in the end it
turned out to be the personal Outlander
this is done doctor's position I will
move on
[Music]
- ice tubers and when he sat down to
ride he often found himself turning in
circles
he also broke a neck vertebra diving
into a pool and was almost paralyzed uh
Avedis I know how you feel overcome with
a kind of humility and tell yourself how
do it might be a good idea to shift down
a gear Shane Mosley immigrants from the
devisor meeting in Managua v.24 she Oh
Sansa shunned amidst mention hi wish me
let's again don't know each door was
called Matar all his latest album the
singer with North African roots gets
political to believe in showing fear
vitae Johnny's right now all this anti
European Union sentiment really worries
me when if my parents came here and
found a wonderful and much better life
to offer us children so it's a great
gift when from dajia assistant courses
to shake our theatre view started out in
the 1990s with a boy band called simply
the boys but after some initial hits the
band dissolved after being exploited by
their management in 2002 audit revealed
met star producer and singer Anita
Hamburg they formed issued age and never
looked back
[Music]
[Applause]
they're three albums sold over three
million copies the eunuchs became a
dream duel
now come tame us Sonali comes from a
loving Egyptian Tunisian family I bet
his mother always doted on him she
probably called him her little sunshine
and that's something that he really does
have inside
Hey Judy was put on hold in 2010
allowing ideal travel to work on his
solo career his debut album promptly
went triple platinum but that success
came at a price times either hobby fish
on one hand I was really happy because I
had finally achieved what I'd always
wanted to do up there on the other hand
a lot went wrong in my private life you
coupled cougar me his marriage with his
wife yes mean broke up in 2014 after a
13-year relationship the tabloids
covered the story extensively
[Music]
that private turmoil was among the
reasons for the new album taking so long
coming but for the artist Oceanos has
been a labor of love
social and azar for me to me it was just
a great statement that fit really well
with the fact that I was making this
album it feels very free as if from now
on I'm only going to do what I feel like
doing lose Tom
[Music]
hop straight from the heart and even
better news for fans in the summer and
fall
advaitha Biel will be taking his new
songs on tool
[Music]
I am understand
you